the iphone 14 is currently by far the
most anticipated smartphone release for
2022
with over two times more searches than
the new samsung galaxy s22 and even
though we've been covering all of the
rumored features like the modernized
iphone 4 style redesign the 48 megapixel
8k capable camera the dual hole punch
notchless display and potentially even
usb type-c replacing lightning there's
one grab-breaking feature that could
rule them all insane levels of battery
life yes there have been some major
innovations in the battery technology
space that can fix a multitude of issues
with today's batteries all at the same
time and i'm going to be covering
exactly what that is and how it's going
to work and why it is so important to
apple now before we begin i just want to
make sure you guys realize how big of a
deal this really is out of all of the
iphone upgrades we have mentioned in the
past i would have to say that upgrading
to the iphone 11 pro max and recently
the new iphone 13s have been my all-time
favorites and while the addition of the
ultrawide camera with the iphone 11 and
120 hertz promotion on the 13 pro were
amazing new features it was actually the
huge jump in battery life that has
changed my life the most because to be
honest it is battery life that allows
you to use all of the iphone features
for longer without having to be stuck
next to a charger or feel like you're
gonna have to turn down your brightness
to last through the day and the same
thing goes for people that want to be
able to have a smaller phone like the
regular 13 instead of buying a max or
maybe even the 13 mini where battery
life allows you to actually be able to
use a small phone without those
limitations so with that said let's get
into this new battery technology
revolution and how it is going to
benefit apple way back in 2020
researchers at mit made a breakthrough
with solid state battery technology
which could allow phones to last for
days without needing a recharge and the
way that it works is by replacing some
of the liquid components inside today's
lithium batteries with solid ones in
today's lithium batteries there is a
liquid electrolyte which lithium ions
use to travel back and forth between the
anode and the cathode or in other words
the positive and the negative components
while the battery is in use these liquid
components are highly volatile and
they're the sole reason that the
batteries can catch on fire like the
galaxy note 7 back in the day and the
beauty of having a solid state battery
is that they would instantly become much
more safe and less prone to fires but
even better it would allow the anode
within batteries to be made of much
better material like pure lithium which
is much more efficient and will allow
for higher energy density however there
is also a major downside to this new
technology as the battery is recharged
the atom buildup causes the lithium
metal to expand and that could also lead
to electrolyte fracturing which could be
even more dangerous so mit invented a
new technology which literally uses
carbon nanotubes to solve this battery
expansion issues these nanotubes are
infused with solid lithium metal to form
the battery's anode and because there is
extra space inside of each of the tubes
the lithium metal has spare room to
expand and shrink while in use so the
major benefit of this is that the
external dimensions of the batteries are
completely unchanged and with no
swelling whatsoever and the beauty of
all of this together with the new
cathode technology is that it can lead
to smartphones of the same size and
weight that only need to be charged once
every three days hence the 72 hour
battery life now before you ask what the
heck does all this have to do with apple
well they have actually filed for
patents for battery battery tech that
sounds extremely similar to what mit
found first of all apple has been
working with the us government on new
coatings for cathode materials to
improve battery life by using lithanium
titanium and germanium coatings instead
of the usual aluminum coatings to
provide increased average voltage and
improved energy retention and as you can
see in these patent images apple will be
able to get higher battery capacity as
voltage goes up compared to dropping off
with the current batteries but this
isn't even a bombshell battery patent
that i want to show you guys last year
apple filed for a patent that would
allow apple to use larger batteries in
future iphones by eliminating wasted
space and using anti-swelling technology
this patent involves using a metal can
battery which is basically a rigid
battery housing or enclosure which keeps
the battery components separate from the
rest of the iphone and before i explain
why they would want to do this let me
remind you that this is exactly what mit
was talking about with their solid state
battery tech the main point is that
there is currently wasted space in the
interior of a smartphone to allow the
battery enough room to expand and
contract so it doesn't end up blowing up
or causing a fire do you guys remember
the galaxy note 7 that was recalled
because of the number of battery fires
that were happening well that is because
samsung pushed the battery size to the
limits without allowing enough internal
space for the battery expansion and so
that fires started to happen but apple
on the other hand is careful to reduce
the size of the battery to avoid this
problem which also really sucks because
it leads to lost potential battery size
it just takes one glance at ifixit's
iphone 13 pro x-ray image by creative
electron to realize just how much
internal space is currently wasted
because of this whole battery swelling
issue and now it becomes really obvious
why apple would want to move over to a
new solid state battery as soon as
possible since it would allow them to
use larger batteries in the iphone
without having to make the iphone larger
itself and i think that this is
extremely important to apple because if
you've seen the leaked design of the
iphone 14 you could see the apple is
going to have ceramic glass protruding
out of the back and front similar to the
design of the iphone 4s and
unfortunately the only way to make this
iphone design not as thick as a brick is
to reduce the thickness of the metal
chassis on the inside of the glass
sandwich which of course will limit the
internal space available for the battery
and if you don't believe me apple filed
for a patent back in 2020 for a whole
new thinner iphone design that includes
multiple structure layers which could be
made out of fiberglass hybrid and
titanium metal which could potentially
be apple's idea for the iphone 14 design
one thin titanium slab sandwiched by two
ceramic glass hybrid layers and of
course the secret to making this all
work without sacrificing battery life
would be to jam in the biggest battery
possible and the best way to do that is
to use up all of that wasted space i
showed you in that x-ray image and all
of this leads back to mit's solid state
battery technology breakthrough which
will use carbon nanotubes to completely
self-contain any battery swelling so
that the battery housing could be solid
filling up the entire internal structure
and space available but the benefits
don't end there in the solid state
battery video example it shows that
using this tech would not only increase
battery life but also enable faster
charging rates which is something apple
users have been asking for years so
basically this new tech is the cream of
the crop and i fully believe that apple
is working on this because of the metal
key and battery patent that apple filed
for which could only be solved by using
a solid state battery and if apple were
to implement it today it could literally
lead to an iphone 13 pro max with 72
hour battery life because of having much
less wasted space that allows for a much
larger battery while also using much
more efficient and energy dense
materials or on the other hand apple
could go back to creating even thinner
iphones kind of like the thin titanium
middle layer we see in the recent iphone
14 design leaks but with added features
like an always on display without
sacrificing any battery life compared to
older models compared to you know what
we have today and that would be awesome
that is a feature that we have wanted
for many years now and all of this could
come with an even safer battery that
doesn't have the same battery fire risk
that other smartphones used to have
which is a win-win so with all that said
if you guys enjoy this video click that
circle above to help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]